et le petit dernier pas mal hein j'ai un
peu la tête dans le pâté au plus tôt
dans les pattes et bon d'accord ce n'est
pas moi qui les ai confectionné
mais croyez moi ça n'a pas été simple de
réunir tout ce beau monde
et puis comme on dit et l'important
c'est de participer
et là où je sens que l'on va avoir
besoin de moi c'est pour vous raconter
l'histoire extraordinaire de ce plat que
georges pano mais tellement son nom fait
polémique
alors qu'est ce qui se cache derrière
cette chose aujourd'hui on va briser la
carapace au plus tôt car c'est la croûte
[Musique]
on l'avait un peu rangé au placard ce
plat typiquement français est en train
de faire son grand retour
il devient même tendance alors de quoi
s'agit-il exactement
d'une pâte faite de farine de beurre
d'eau de sel certains y ajoutent même d
eux rien d'obligatoire
la pâte est déposé dans un moule
traditionnellement rectangulaire et à
l'intérieur de la pâte on va faire cuire
une farce constitué de plusieurs vies
rentrent plus ou moins haché avec des
épices et des herbes
selon votre goût une fois l'ensemble
cuit on mange tout bon ça c'est
aujourd'hui mais ça n'a pas toujours été
le cas
suivez moi ce plat apparaît au moyen-âge
à cette époque est celle et ceux qui le
prépare n'utilise pas de récipients
c'est la patte qui une fois façonné fait
office de contenant et ce sont les
pâtissiers qui s'en charge parce qu'il
dispose d'un bon four et qu'ils savent
faire la pâte
elle est très épaisse pour éviter à la
viande de brûler une fois cuites et bien
le forme une croûte qui permet de
conserver la farce
elle est si épaisse qu'elle ne se mange
pas on la brise on la met de côté et on
déguste ce qu'il ya à l'intérieur bon tu
vas le dire oui ou non
pâté en croûte c'est pas un gros mot
quand même aïe
j'en vois qui fronce les sourcils il est
là le problème
même les grands chefs n'arrivent pas à
se mettre d'accord c'est un petit peu
comme l'histoire du pain au chocolat et
de la chocolatine
étymologiquement l'appellation pâté en
croûte et même un pléonasme car le pâté
c'est la patte dans son livre mots de
table mon de bouche
claudine brécourt villard se rappelle
que pathé est un dérivé de pâte utilisée
dès le douzième siècle
il est d'abord appliqué à une pâtisserie
puis par extension à partir du xvième
siècle à une charcuterie enveloppé dans
une croûte
autrement dit le pâté c'est la patte
c'est l'ensemble la croûte bombe alors
qu'est ce qu'on vit bien
si on s'en tient à la lettre on devrait
dire pathé mais ce terme ayant été
étendu à d'autres charcuteries et qu'il
faut bien distinguer celles ci si
particulière des autres eh bien on parle
même si sa valeur de certaines oreilles
de pâté en croûte pâté croûte dans la
région lyonnaise
c'est une farce non elle la farce je les
dis se trouve à l'intérieur
d'ailleurs en ce qui concerne la farce
chaque région quasiment à sa recette on
peut citer le pâté lorrain à base de
porc et de vaud le pâté de chartres avec
du perdreau du faisan et du foie gras
que l'on retrouve aussi dans le pâté en
croûte richelieu bonne idée
dans tous les sens du terme que l'on
doit selon la légende au cardinal
lui-même dans le pâté de pâques on met
un neuf
mais quoi qu'il en soit pour mériter son
nom le pâté en croûte doit contenir au
moins une moitié de viande mais le plus
audacieux
c'est celui là l'oreiller de la belle
aurore plus de 15 villes différentes
pour un poids total avoisinant et 15 kg
c'est vrai qu'après avoir mangé tout ça
au nom envie de se mettre la tête sous
l'oreiller et de ne pas se réveiller
avant l'aurore
pas du tout c'est un hommage à la mère
d'anselme brillat savarin c'est un
personnage que tous les gastronomes
connaissent il a donné son nom
un délicieux fromage il était magistrat
mais il aimait aussi la bonne table
en 1825 à la fin de sa vie il a rédigé
un ouvrage qui fait référence auprès de
tous les amateurs de cuisine elle
physiologie du goût sa mère baptisé
aurore semble être à l'origine de ce
pâté si particulier du coup ça m'a
réveillé les papilles ces histoires un
peu de patience car en général
l'oreiller de la belle aurore se déguste
à l'automne il y a encore quelques
années le pâté en croûte ne faisait plus
recette on le trouvait fade disgracieux
totalement démodé au salut jean croûte
pardon je ne voulais pas de vexer jean
croûte
c'est la mascotte officielle du pâté en
croûte et il a raison de s'offusquer car
aujourd'hui le pâté en croûte ça
ressemble plutôt à ça ou à ça des pièces
uniques qui font penser à des oeuvres
d'art en 2000
plusieurs chefs décident de le remettre
au goût du jour
il crée et la confrérie du pâté en
croûte et organise même un championnat
du monde
professionnels et amateurs venus du
monde entier s'y affrontent chaque année
en disant c'est devenu une véritable
institution
et c'est très sérieux les réalisations
sont toutes plus inventifs que les
autres
les viandes peuvent être mariner dans du
cognac de l'armagnac du marc de
champagne de bourgogne la farce contient
des champignons des pistaches la gelée
comble les vides
quant à la pâte elle soit brisée soit
feuilletée toutes ces caractéristiques
sont minutieusement scruté par le jury
il évalue la pièce entière les aussi les
tranches une fois qu'elles sont coupées
la cuisson la farce bien sûr l'equilibre
de l'ensemble c'est si beau et si
photogénique que le pâté en croûte est
devenu une star d'instagram alors il a
beaucoup de follower le pâté en croûte
il a surtout des milliers de like sa
notoriété a même dépassé les frontières
en 2019 c'est un chef japonais qui a
remporté le titre de champion du monde
du pâté en faute et deux ans plus tôt en
2017 deviner ce qu'il y avait au menu du
dîner
de gala entre emmanuel macron et
l'ancien président américain donald kohn
en visite à paris du pacte et en croûte
du pâté en croûte croûte toc route s'ils
attendent succès aujourd'hui c'est qu'il
s'agit d'un mais raffinée et
contemporain qui met en avant et les
produits du terroir français
bref il envoie du pâté et ses pages en
croûte qui dira le contraire depuis que
la peluche et commercialisé il s'en vend
des centaines salut jean froot
quant à nous on se retrouve très vite
pour une nouvelle vidéo d'ici là
n'hésitez pas à me donner en commentaire
votre recette préférée du pâté en croûte
et bien sûr abonnez vous salut si vous
avez aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à
laisser un pouce bleus merci les épis
curieux pour les plus gourmands en voici
l'autre et pour ne rien rater
abonnez vous et activer la cloche
[Applaudissements]